[Musique]
bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition de présidentielle
360 voici les titres à l'hommage de la
nation à xavier juguler le policier tué
sur les champs elysées françois hollande
a demandé aux élus de demain de données
en forces de l'ordre les moyens
nécessaires pour assurer la protection
des français
le chef de l'état qui rappelle à
emmanuel macron que rien n'est fait il
convient d'être extrêmement sérieux et
mobiliser parce qu'un run je cite ça se
mérite ça se conquiert ça se justifie ça
se porte la droite au bord de
l'implosion après son élimination du
second tour de la présidentielle
sarkozyste et juppéiste se réunissent
pour tirer les enseignements de la
défaite à gauche le ps affaibli par une
débâcle électorale sans précédent espère
encore peser dans la future majorité
en cas de victoire d'emmanuel macron
reportage à suivre
comment le front national est il parvenu
à réaliser un score historique avec plus
de 7 millions de voix marine le pen est
arrivé en tête dans 47 départements
elle conforte ses bastions tout en
conquérant de nouveaux territoires
décryptage avec mon invité l'historienne
spécialiste de l'extrême droite valérie
igounet et je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez réagir à cette émission sur
twitter avec le hashtag présidentielle à
pour françois hollande l'enjeu c'est que
le front national soit plus le plus
faible possible au second tour le chef
de l'état sort de sa réserve et souligne
que ce n'est pas la même chose pour un
pays de savoir que l'extrême droite est
à 20 30 ou 40%
je pense dit il qu'il convient d'être
extrêmement sérieux et mobiliser et de
ne pas penser est bien que rien n'est
fait car un vote ça se mérite ça se
conquiert
ça se porte aussi c'est un avertissement
du chef de l'état emmanuel macron
s'était alors d'un déplacement à laval
et puis françois hollande a rendu ce
matin un hommage aux policiers tués lors
de l'attentât terroriste perpétré jeudi
dernier sur les champs-elysées
le chef de l'état qui avait convié à cet
hommage république et en marine le pen
emmanuel macron qui s'affronteront au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
mounir souci recueillement et tristesse
dans la cour d'honneur de la préfecture
de police
paris pour l'hommage à xavier juge les
ses camarades étaient rassemblés autour
de nombreux responsables politiques de
droite et de gauche
la famille du policier étaient aussi
présentes et c'est son compagnon qui
s'est chargé de saluer sa personnalité
empreinte de tolérance et de délivrer un
message émouvant et pour ce qui me
concerne je souffre 100 m
j'emprunte cette formule antoine leiris
dont l'immense sagesse face à la douleur
a tant fait mon admiration que j'avais
lu et relu ces lignes il ya quelques
mois
c'est une leçon de vie qui m'avait fait
en grand dire qu'elle me protège
aujourd'hui xavier juge les a été élevé
à titre posthume au rang de capitaine
est fait chevalier de la légion
d'honneur le président de la république
a rappelé que cet agent avait assisté
les victimes du bataclan après les
attentats du 13 novembre
il a aussi adressé une recommandation
aux deux finalistes de l'élection
présidentielle aux élus ici présents qui
rompt a décidé pour demain je leur
demande d'accorder les ressources
budgétaires nécessaires pour recruter
des personnels indispensables à la
protection de nos concitoyens
françois hollande a appelé tous les
français à soutenir les forces de
l'ordre rappelant que huit policiers et
14 gendarmes ont trouvé la mort l'année
dernière dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions
va-t-on vers une crise chez les élèves
après l'élimination de françois fillon
l'heure des comptes est arrivé ce matin
à nicolas sarkozy et réunissait ses
proches à l'ancien président s'activent
pour préparer la bataille des
législatives tandis qu'une réunion est
prévue ce soir autour du maire de
bordeaux alain juppé
cécile siksou et eloïse grégoire vous
monsieur rendez vous matinal pour les
sarkozystes
à la sortie il y a ceux qui voteront
pour emmanuel macron je le battrai
macron par défaut totalement par des y'a
pas de campagne ou maquereau n'y a pas
de soutien maman il n'y a pas d'alliance
avec ma compte les choses soient très
très simple on combattra macro
législatives
quand on a le choix entre macouin le pen
moi je vois très maintenant est ce
qu'ils ne peuvent s'y résoudre
je peux pas j'ai des désaccords
absolument fondamentaux avec lui sur un
certain nombre de sujets majeurs
le combat s'est macron c'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'il va falloir tracté pour
mac ont jusqu'au 7 mai c'est pas
possible
divisées sur le cas macron les
sarkozystes temps surtout d'imposer en
ligne pour les législatives
l'autre enjeu reprendre en main le parti
et placer leurs hommes à sa tête se
lance ce défi qu'est de remporter des
élections initiative faut qu'on explique
terme en français qui sera premier
ministre en cas de victoire et nous
voilà celui qui sera promu nice en cas
de victoire ce sera françois baroin eric
woerth pas se mobiliser pour le projet
laurent wauquiez dans l'animation du
parti avec bernard acoyer et puis
christian jacob également s'impliquer
dans la campagne
quelques heures plus tard premières
retrouvailles des républicains au sénat
depuis l'élection et premier point de
rupture au sein du groupe
contrairement aux sarkozystes les
juppéiste eux ne ferme pas la porte à
emmanuel macron nous ne pourrons pas
ignorer le résultat de la présidentielle
et nous opposer surtout ce serait
destructeur au moment où la france a
besoin de réformes
donc l'idée d'une une coalition mais qui
n'est pas la tradition française plutôt
de tradition germanique
c'est à dire un accord de gouvernement
un accord sur certaines mesures
nous souhaiterions qu emmanuel macron
infléchisse son projet les fillonnistes
quant à eux digère encore leur défaite
et attendent les législatives pour
parler recomposition politique de la
droite à gauche
48 heures après la débâcle de benoît
hamon les parlementaires ps espère
encore pouvoir peser on l'a fait future
majorité gouvernementale en cas de
victoire d'emmanuel macron mais les
divergences demeurent sur la stratégie
adoptée
sandra cerqueira et flora sauvage
réunion à huis clos du groupe socialiste
au sénat pour parler de la déroute à la
présidentielle et surtout des
législatives pour jean pierre sueur
comme pour beaucoup de
sociaux-démocrates du ps
aucune hésitation il faut créer une
vraie coalition à l'allemande avec
emmanuel macron seule façon de sauver un
maximum de députés socialistes pour être
au second tour il faut faire 21 22 23 %
bon si vous avez une pluralité de
candidats et que personne n'obtient cela
est bien qu'est ce qui se passe on peut
avoir ce second tour droite front
national
sauf que pour l'instant ce ne sont pas
les conditions posées par emmanuel
macron
être candidat en marche tout en restant
au parti socialiste est impossible une
règle que bon nombre de ténors au ps
tente de changer françois patriat fait
partie de la commission qui sélectionne
les candidats en marche
il avoue être très sollicité choqués les
élus qui souhaitent et candidat demain
ce ne soit pas lui doivent leur âme et
confiance démontré leur capacité à
demain être des soutiens sans faille du
président de république
il s'agit pas de reconstruire des
groupes qui demain seront les fraudeurs
de demain où des gens qui disent rond
parce que demandera une coalition une
coalition dans laquelle tel ou tel
posera plus ou moins de poids il pouvoir
un pourra influer influencer les choix
les valses east entendent de créer un
groupe indépendant à l'assemblée pour
peser dans la future majorité
présidentielle on peut penser beaucoup
de choses emmanuel macron c'est normal
mais il était membre du gouvernement
ministre de l'économie considère
françois hollande et tout d'un coup mais
je deviendrai de droite donc il ya un
moment ça s'appelle du bonneteau c'est
plus de la politique donc là il faut un
peu se ressaisir voilà la parenthèse
hamon est finie faut sortir un peu des
rêves d'enfants et re devenir adulte les
grandes manoeuvres au ps ont donc bien
commencé en vue des législatives et la
droite compte bien profiter des
divisions pour sauver un maximum de
députés et imposer une cohabitation
futur président est toujours en vue des
législatives le secrétaire national du
parti communiste est sénateur de paris
pierre laurent lance un appel à la
france insoumise de jean-luc mélenchon
pour les candidatures de rassemblement
dans le plus possible et de
circonscription on écoute la reconquête
engagé le 23 avril peut donc se
poursuivre mais elle se poursuivra à une
condition que les forces qui ont permis
ensemble le score de jean luc mélenchon
en voit très vite un signal fort de mise
en commun de leur énergie dans cette
nouvelle bataille législative
c'est donc l'appel que je lance
aujourd'hui notamment à la france un
soumises dont je ne comprends pas le
silence à nos appels pour une discussion
commune sur les législatives depuis
dimanche et c'est l'appel que je lance à
toutes les forces de gauche
qui sont prêtes elles aussi à s'en
saisir le temps presse et françois
bayrou président du modem invité de
notre émission l'épreuve de vérité a
vivement critiqué le choix de jean-luc
mélenchon de ne donner aucune consigne
de vote on les écoute j'ai été stupéfait
qu'il ne se prononcent pas dimanche soir
j'aurai j'aurais parié à peu près de
tout ce que j'avais que ça ne serait pas
le cas et comme le disait monsieur vous
compreniez que sont blessés tous ceux
qui avaient mis leur confiance ou en
tout cas l'immense majorité de ceux qui
avaient mis le riviera de recevoir le
discours de m je vois bien les
tentatives qui sont pour piper les voies
et pour essayer d'élargir une base
électorale mais je ne crois pas une
seconde que les citoyens femmes et
hommes qui vont se prononcer dans cette
élection se laisse abuser par par ses
discours
voilà émission à revoir dans son
intégralité ce soir sur notre antenne
dès 18h30 à bruxelles les eurodéputés
ont également commenté les résultats du
premier tour de la présidentielle si les
europhiles sont soulagés de voir que
marine le pen n'est pas arrivé en tête
du scrutin français la perspective de sa
victoire inquiète écoutez et ses
réactions recueillies aujourd'hui par
nos ramadi du côté de l'allemagne
nous sommes extrêmement soulagés qu'il y
a un candidat pro européen au deuxième
tour
est-ce qui a été extrêmement positif
c'est qu'il a même eu beaucoup plus de
voix au premier tour qu'on avait pensé
madame le pen a gagné tant de voix que
cela mais je me fais beaucoup de souci
pour cela parce qu'on voit très bien que
beaucoup de personnes ne se sentent pas
rassuré dans l'europe d'aujourd'hui
et là je pense qu'il faudra beaucoup
travailler je crois que les manuels
macron s'il ne veut pas d'une part
connaître le sort de valéry giscard
d'estaing parce que le parallèle entre
les deux personnages est assez est assez
frappant s'il ne veut pas connaître son
sort et surtout s'il veut réconcilier
les français avec l'idée d'intégration
européenne je pense qu'il aura un gros
travail pas pédagogie mais de
d'orientation politique à faire parce
que si ça son concept c'est simplement
de flexibiliser le marché du travail de
réduire la dépense publique d'augmenter
la compétition d'ouvrir la france aux
fins de rentrer dans cette dynamique de
ce traité de libre-échange d'inspiration
néolibérale
je crains fort qu'il renforce un terme
la l'insurrection national populiste qui
est menée aujourd'hui par marine le pen
et on continue à l'analyse et le
décryptage des enjeux de ce second tour
de l'élection présidentielle avec vous
thème traduit et bonsoir vous allez
passer bien au crible les propositions
des deux candidats finalistes a lors de
cette campagne mieux emmanuel macron
face à marine le pen
on s'intéresse aujourd'hui un cas précis
c'est le cas de wayne poule que
promettent emmanuel macron et marine le
pen pour cette usine d'amiens qui fait
la une de l'actualité dont la production
doit être délocalisée en pologne
et bien pour emmanuel macron c'est
simple il ne veut pas tomber dans les
écueils de la campagne de 2012 de
françois hollande qui n'a pas pu tenir
ses promesses à l'égard des salariés
d'arcelormittal de florange bien du coup
l'ex ministre de l'économie ne promet
rien tout simplement on écoute je
considère qu'une campagne présidentielle
c'est pas pour faire des propos
d'estrade avec des promesses qu'on sait
pas tenir
donc je ne le fais pas pour will paul je
ne me suis pas saisi des cas en cours
des cachots de restructuration parce que
c'est de la démago complète suit vous
parler franchement pas ce que je vais
faire quoi
je vais aller sur un camion et je vais
le dire avec mouassa fermera pas vous
remarquez au passage en arrière le petit
tacle à françois hollande alors à
l'époque c'était il ya quelques semaines
salarié de whirlpool vivent cette
attitude comme de l'indifférence de la
part de l'enfant du pays 1 puisque
emmanuel macron est originaire d'amiens
défense des manuels macron l'a entendu
il se refuse à un str instrumentalisé et
les cas sensibles dans la campagne aidé
à marine le pen elle n'a pas ce genre de
précautions c'est tout le contraire pour
elle et bien ce cas illustre le drame
des délocalisations pour lesquels elle a
une réponse toute faite en l'écoutant
dont projet présidentiel
j'entends mettre en place une taxation
ou à l'importation pour ces sociétés qui
croient pouvoir aller faire des supers
profits en délocalisant dans des
produits dans des pays à bas coûts et
donc bien leurs produits seront taxés à
35% si les revendre sur le territoire
national après avoir délocalisé
donc d'un côté un candidat qui ne se
mouille pas et de l'autre une candidate
qui a une réponse à la crise pour
heureusement ce n'est pas aussi simple
depuis emmanuel macron a promis de se
rendre sur place dans l'entre-deux-tours
ce qu'il va faire d'ailleurs demain à
midi tandis que marine le pen elle lors
de sa campagne à visiter très peu d'
usine et que pour l'heure rien n'est
prévu pour visiter l usine d'amiens dans
son agenda
plus largement tam que disent les
programmes économiques des candidats les
programmes aussi en ce qui concerne
l'industrie
la première vue c'est plutôt surprenant
mais on peut tout de même trouvé
quelques points d'accord entre marine le
pen et emmanuel macron d'abord sur des
points sur lequel il ya consensus pour
tous les candidats
par exemple pour réformer le régime
social des indépendants je rappelle que
ça avait été qualifiée de catastrophe
industrielle à part la cour des comptes
ou encore pour lutter contre l'
optimisation une évasion fiscale là
dessus tout le monde est d'accord mais
il ya d'autres points plus signifiants
par exemple la réduction de l'impôt sur
les sociétés ou encore la baisse des
cotisations sociales et patronales alors
du côté de marine le pen
ça s'explique par le fait qu'elle est
favorable à une baisse générale des
impôts et du côté à des manuels macro
c'est un marqueur qui a plus de 100
suite veut libérer et d'économie
d'escrocs qui l'entravent on se rappelle
d'ailleurs que c'était bien la
philosophie de la loi macro mais aussi
des différences dame qu'est ce qui les
oppose fondamentalement pour l'essentiel
bien sûr ce sont deux philosophies a
quasiment inversés emmanuel macron est
un européen à libera tandis que marine
le pen utilise l'industrie pour
promouvoir l'une des thématiques les
plus importantes dans son programme
c'est à dire eh bien la fermeture des
frontières et le refus de l'étranger
donc du côté de marine le pen à par le
grand plan de réindustrialisation dont
elle parle et le retour de l'état
stratège mais qui reste assez fou
d'ailleurs dans ses propositions et bien
tout s'articule autour de la sortie de
l'euro et on sait que beaucoup
d'économistes estiment que cela pourrait
être un grand chaos au niveau européen
et autour du protectionnisme avec
notamment le fait de réserver la
commande publique aux entreprises
françaises ou encore une taxe
supplémentaire sur une embauche des
salariés étrangers pour assurer je la
cite à la priorité nationale pour les
français ou encore par exemple la mise
en place d'une autorité de sûreté
économique pour contrôler les
investissements étrangers qui pourrait
nuire aux intérêts français
que prévoit emmanuel macron face aux
effets de la démondialisation et bien
faire une idée mise à l'écart de la
mondialisation à l'est synonyme avant
tout aux opportunités mais ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il ne cherche pas non plus à
protéger la france mais pour lui pour
protéger efficacement la france il faut
mettre les barrières au niveau européen
et non un national y cite notamment le
cas de la chine ou encore des états unis
de là pour lui l'europe doit faire la
même chose se doter d'outils pour lutter
contre les attaques d'états
extracommunautaires il propose par
exemple via l'instauration d'un contrôle
européen sur les investissements
étrangers qui pourraient nuire aux
entreprises stratégiques
il propose aussi de renforcer tout ce
qui est procédures européennes
antidumping et enfin il propose un bail
européenne acte pour réserver l'accès
aux marchés publics européens aux
entreprises qui localise moins la moitié
de leur production en france
et pour finir je voudrais tout de même
parler d'un dernier point le fait qu'ils
maniaient mâcon propose de réformer
l'isf et l'impôt sur la fortune pour le
remplacer pour un impôt sur la fortune
immobilière ce qui exclurait donc les
actions les par les titres d'entreprises
l'objectif pour lui est bien c'est bien
de favoriser l'investissement productif
et innovant est plus l'investissement
immobilier
mais au passage ça favoriserait aussi et
très grandes fortunes
merci tam pour votre analyse on continue
justement est bien à parler en deux
marine le pen car elle veut être la
candidate du peuple et du terrain était
dès le lever du jour à rungis le marché
de gros de paris l'occasion pour elle de
développer ses positions sur le
protectionnisme mais vous allez le voir
l'accueil a été plutôt mitigé quand un
calme et ne pas perdre une seconde et
occuper le terrain la candidate
frontiste dévoile ainsi sa stratégie
pour le second tour
arrivé aux aurores pour visiter rungis
marine le pen enchaîne les scènes fille
et les poignées de mains au pas de
course
l'occasion aussi de reparler de
souveraineté économique quitte à se
faire contredire par son hôte
je voudrais que dans les assiettes des
employés les productions françaises dans
les estrades certains produits on est
dépendant titan lannion part on est
dépendant mai
mais est on peut pas changer ça non ça a
des chances que vous aurez du mal à
changer encore dans certaines
productions
mais malgré cela marine le pen assume
son protectionnisme économique et des
frontières
on protège on se protège de la
concurrence déloyale quand il ya une
concurrence déloyale
eh bien on met des écluses ont dit non
il ya une réglementation pouvez pas vous
permettre de faire ça et on rétablit une
concurrence loyale
parce que sinon on va tous mourir un
déplacement le deuxième depuis le
lancement de la campagne de l'entre-deux
tours quand emmanuel macron lui attend
encore pour repartir sur le terrain une
visite où marine le pen a également été
hué principale difficulté pour la
candidate rassembler au delà de son
parti christine boutin est la seule
personnalité pour l'heure à avoir
annoncé qu'elle voterait marine le pen
[Musique]
et mon invité ce soir valérie gones et
bonsoir vous êtes historienne chercheuse
associée à l'institut du temps présent
c'est les restes spécialiste de
l'extrême droite et du négationnisme
vous avez écrit cet ouvrage l'illusion
national avec vincent jarousseau deux
enquêtes dans les villes fn vous avez
choisi est bien de nous livrer une
plongée au coeur des nains beaumont
hayange et beaucaire sous forme de roman
photo
quand vous voyez marine le pen au second
tour sans susciter finalement les mois
qu'on avait pu connaître en 2002 avec
jean marie le pen qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
de l'étonnement c'est à dire que c'est
vrai pour rappeler brièvement les faits
en 2002 jean marie le pen est élue mais
elle a à la surprise générale il obtient
16,9 pour cent des voix mais c'est vrai
qu'on les citoyens français le monde
politique est en émoi les intellectuels
et c est très très vite quelques heures
après quelques minutes après la
promulgation des résultats il y à des
manifestations qu'ils s'organisent dans
les rues de paris et dans d'autres rues
et évidemment donc parti s'est banalisé
est-ce que c'est ce travail de
dédiabolisation qui a porté ses fruits
qui conduit à cette situation bien sûr
c'est déjà ça alors la grosse différence
c'est aussi que tout le monde
s'attendait à cette seconde place alors
après avec un résultat plus ou moins
élevés ou différent de suite celui qui
est là mais il ya déjà cet aspect on
s'attendait à cette élection après oui
bien sûr et on le voit bien parce que
vous dites le parti s'est banalisé il a
été d diaboliser est-ce que vous pouvez
employer cette expression de
lepénisation des esprits c'est ce qu'on
avait dit aussi à un moment qui est
présente depuis peut-être aussi la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy qui avait
été très à droite en 2007 alors
lepénisation des esprits j'irais pas
jusqu'a là c'est vrai que cette campagne
ait eu nicolas sarkozy n'en a pas fait
mystère il avait pris les mots du front
national pour séduire ses électeurs et
ça avait fonctionné aujourd'hui c'est
pas ça exactement ce qui se passe c'est
que marine le pen son parti prend de
plus en plus de place d'audience déjà
parce qu'elle présente un et par cette
banalisation et 7 dédiabolisation mais
aussi par ce que ne font pas les partis
traditionnels et c'est ce qui se révèle
aussi dans ce premier tour c'est à dire
cette disparition
des deux partis principaux sous la vème
république alors marine le pen réalise
un score historique avec 164 millions de
voix soit 1,22 million de bulletins
supplémentaires quels sont les ressorts
des électeurs est ce qu'ils ont dans
leur motivation de vote évoluer
également par rapport aux dernières
élections
je pense que ce qui est principal vous
savez il ya toujours cette distinction
entre le vote d'adhésion et le vote de
rejet
c'est vrai qu'on en sait aujourd'hui que
l'adhésion et le rejet se rejoignent
alors que par exemple dans les années
2000 le vote de rejet était principal
voyez donc il ya déjà ça mais il ya
aussi évidemment d'autres catégories de
population qui entendent marine le pen
autrement et qui votent pour ce parti et
je pense notamment aux ouvriers
ça c'est ça a commencé dans les années
90 à la présidentielle de 95 c'est
aujourd'hui on voit bien que ça s'est
accentué mais vous voyez bien aussi les
résultats de ce premier tour les
territoires ruraux commence à être
acquis à sopot fn et c'est eric star où
il ya d'autres catégories qui s'ouvre on
vote front national il faut pas
l'oublier
justement vous parlez de ces territoires
oubliés c'est son discours elle
s'adresse à cette france est des
oubliées elles arrivent en première
position dans 47 départements 216 la
circonscription il y à certains scores
inédits notamment pour l'outre-mer la
corse
quelle lecture justement faites vous
cette nouvelle implantation géographique
du front national c'est que lecture
c'est que le front national est en train
de réussir un c'est paris c'est à dire
d'avoir cette entente
voyez cette réception auprès d'autres
territoires mais aussi auprès d'autres
populations comme je disais précédemment
c'est vrai que elle a un discours qui
s'élargit quand on lit ces 144
engagement on voit bien que s'est
adressé à ce peuple comme elle l'appelle
de droite à ce peuple de gauche est
évidemment aussi à ce peuple originel
qui est l'extrême droite radicale au
sein de son parti et vous voyez il ya
cette audience qui s'accroît aussi par
ces différentes mesures qui sont ciblés
ces différentes paroles qu'ils entendent
bien sûr et ses différents territoires
on voit son choix de stratégie d'une
campagne très proches du terrain très
actif dans cet entre deux tours vous qui
avez parlé justement à ces électeurs qui
ne votent effet lassé
habitants qui sont gérés par des
municipalités frontiste que vous ont-ils
dit justement je pense par exemple aux
habitants d'hénin-beaumont puisqu'elle
était là bas dimanche j'ai pensé à eux
évidemment qu'est ce qu'ils nous ont dit
ils nous ont dit déjà que c'était pour
eux un nouveau parti ça c'est très
intéressant envoyé puisque pour eux le
front national de jean marie le pen
n'existe plus avec celui de marine le
pen donc ça c'est la première chose la
seconde chose aussi qui l'ont souligné
c'est qu'ils ne croient plus en cette
politique auquel ils ont longtemps cru
les années précédentes donc ensuite
partis traditionnels comme je disais
tout à l'heure et la troisième chose
c'était un contexte spécifique illusion
nationale puisque c'était pendant les
attentats a envoyé la troisième chose
c'est qu'ils adhèrent totalement au
marqueur principaux du front national
c'est à dire mais nos phobies
immigration insécurité dans sa faut pas
l'oublier ou plus
on sait bien que françois hollande est
intervenu dans cet après midi pour
mettre en garde emmanuel macron rien
n'est fait ils voient leur attention il
ya cette victoire possible selon vous de
marine le pen au second tour
le soir de l'élection je me disais que
la victoire était impossible
et aujourd'hui je me dis qu qu'elle est
impossible je pense qu'elle est
fortement compromise par rapport au
contexte par rapport à ce parti ce
qu'ils proposent et par rapport quand
même à cette réaction à la majorité des
français aujourd'hui disent bien qu'ils
rejettent le front national
mais c'est vrai que je pense que les
cartes sont quasiment jetés mais il faut
quand même être vigilant oui tout à fait
on voit bien qu'elle parle d'un vieux
front républicain tout pourrir wii se
met en place autour d'elle elle elle
pourrait quand même en bénéficier selon
vous non je vous dis je pense que non
elle va pas pour moi il ne peut pas être
présidente de la république cette année
mais c'est vrai que si les choses
évoluent ou continue comme ça je me dis
que en 2022
il faut encore être plus vigilant quoi
oui eh bien merci
valérie gkn et pour votre analyse merci
d'être venu dans cette émission c'est la
fin de cette édition merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi à 22h vont trouver sonia
mabrouk et seront émises
on va plus loin très bonne soirée à tous
et à demain 18h
[Musique]